bonsoir à tous nous sommes lundi 26
septembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres un plan d'accueil a été décidée
par le préfet pour accueillir des
migrants dans les yvelines 400 personnes
devraient arriver sur notre territoire
les maires du canton du chesnay
concernés par cette décision
ils sont opposés en opération propreté à
guyancourt ce week end un grand
évènement chasse aux déchets était
organisée une tonne de détritus a été
ramassé aux étangs de la minière nous y
reviendrons et enfin nous vous
présenterons le nouveau restaurant
d'alain ducasse installé dans le château
de versailles un argument peut-être ou
faire revenir à les visiteurs et ravivé
l'engouement autour de ce lieu
touristique et cette information pour
commencer ce matin vers 11h45 des coups
de feu ont éclaté à plusieurs reprises
devant un supermarché de port marly le
tireur est un homme retraité habitant de
port marly l'a ouvert le feu sur une
caissière alors en pause devant
l'enseigné sur un homme âgé de 73 ans
les deux victimes ont été transportées à
l'hôpital
elles sont grièvement blessés le
pronostic vital du septuagénaire est
engagé le raid est intervenu dans cette
affaire le tireur s'est rendu peu après
16 heures après s'être retranché chez
lui
la brigade criminelle de la police
judiciaire de versailles a été saisie de
l'enquêté et nous vous en parlions la
semaine dernière l'information est
désormais avérée de candidats que de
migrants devrait ouvrir sous peu dans
les yvelines notamment art concourent
également à louveciennes une des saisies
une décision pardon du préfet des
yvelines vendredi les maires de ces
communes ainsi que ceux des communes
avoisinantes ont tenu une conférence de
presse afin de clarifier la situation
mais aussi d'expliquer leur désarroi
face à une décision prise trop
rapidement selon eux regarder des
migrants accueillis dans les yvelines
la décision a été confirmée par le
préfet
les maires du canton du chesnay incluant
bougival la celle saint cloud rocancourt
et louveciennes ont appris la nouvelle
vendredi matin ils ont tenu une
conférence de presse pour exprimer leur
position face à ce plan d'accueil à
rocquencourt une centaine de migrants
sera accueilli pour une période maximale
de deux mois sur le site de l'inria
on est mis devant le fait accompli et il
est évident que rocancourt déjà 100
migrants dans une commune de 3200
habitants
ça représente 4% de la population et on
estime que c'est déjà beaucoup et qui
sera difficile de de cohabiter de son
côté l'ancien hébergera de façon pérenne
100 à 200 personnes
une situation problématique pour la
commune en effet de l'amiante aurait été
détectée sur le site situé lui même
proche d'une discothèque
en plus de cela un projet d'aménagement
avec des entreprises devrait voir le
jour sur ce site de ville vers un lieu
inadapté pour recevoir autant de
personnes selon le maire si c'est pour
reproduire ce qui s'est passé à calais
ça j'y suis totalement enfin dans la
danse dans l'esprit j'y suis totalement
opposé en tout cas je suis fermement
opposé à l'installation d'un camp fnac
en 2000 grand sur le site de villevayre
que ce soit 10 que ce soit sans les
problèmes de sécurité sont les mêmes les
deux maires opposés à ces implantations
obtenu du préfet qu'un groupe de travail
de concertation soit mise en place
le plan d'accueil nécessite 400 places
sur l'ensemble des yvelines nous avons
jusqu'à je dirais fin octobre pour
éventuellement trouver des solutions
d'accueil de ces personnes si nous ne
trouvons pas la solution on nous
imposerait la solution de fioles les
migrants pour arriver sur le camp
provisoire de l'inria rocancourt dans
les jours qui viennent
concernant l'ancien l'échéance est
prévue fin octobre début novembre
du côté de la population la colère
gronde une pétition a été lancée par la
ville de louveciennes celle de recours a
déjà obtenu 1300 signatures en quelques
jours et plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont manifesté samedi après
midi à versailles et justement contre ce
projet les manifestants au nombre de 800
environ ont gagné la préfecture où une
délégation a été reçue peu après 16
heures un autre rassemblement était
prévu en fin d'après-midi à
sienne sur le site de la plaine de
villevayre pressenti pour accueillir les
migrants est dans la continuité des
assises de la ruralité la large
consultation lancée en 2015 le
département a réuni le 1er forum à des
maires ruraux la semaine dernière à
bingerville
une façon de mieux comprendre et de
mieux accompagner ses mers sur leur
territoire un reportage signé maximum un
an après les assises de la ruralité le
premier forum des maires ruraux s'est
tenue à bazens ville c'est pour nous la
possibilité de faire le point sur
l'avancement des mesures en faveur de la
ruralité et c'est aussi la possibilité
de prendre le pouls de nos territoires
ruraux
un retour d'expérience plus générale un
échange de bonnes pratiques parfois et
pourquoi pas que ça fasse émerger
certaines idées haut débit accessibilité
et entretien des gares les maires
n'hésite pas à interpeller les
représentants de l'état du conseil
départemental et du sénat venu
participer au forum inquiétudes
prégnante l'urbanisme et le droit du sol
grâce aux assises de la ruralité
cette question avait justement retenu
l'attention de gérard larcher
on est face à trop de complexité trop de
contentieux on est face à trop de
blocages et donc nos rapporteurs ont
fait une deuxième consultation des
maires sur ce qui leur semblait
prioritaires et ceci donne une
proposition de loi qui sera débattue le
28 octobre dans la semaine du 28 octobre
enfin une annonce importante concernant
les contrats ruraux pierre bédier
souhaite que ce soit l' agence
départementale in générique qui s'occupe
de constituer les dossiers afin de
soulager les maires donc le maire lui il
l'aurait qu'à écrire une lettre une
lettre d'intention pour dire le
ce qu'il veut le projet qu'il poursuit
la demande de subvention est comme ça
après on peut aller plus vite
accompagner les maires ruraux une
démarche extrêmement importante pour le
conseil départemental
ce forum se tiendra une à deux fois par
an opération à propreté à guyancourt
samedi avait lieu l'événement chassons
les déchets toute la matinée le club des
jeunes chasseurs d'ile-de-france et des
volontaires ont participé à une matinée
de nettoyage aux étangs de la minière
plus d'une tonne de déchets ont été
ramassés comme vous le montre camille
lambert et nicolas qui y habitent
kenneth mouchoirs pièces en métal la
forêt prend parfois des airs de
déchetterie pour les jeunes chasseurs
d'ile-de-france pas question de se
décourager le 24 septembre ils ont
organisé l'opération chassons les
déchets une matinée de nettoyage aux
étangs de la minière et guyancourt
aujourd'hui on est là pour sensibiliser
les jeunes avec les scouts et les jeunes
chasseurs afin de dire voilà faut
travailler dès le départ et avoir une
bonne éducation dès le départ et ne pas
acheter
c'est plus agréable de chasse et de se
balader de courir de faire du vélo dans
une forêt propre scouts jeunes chasseurs
sympathisants une cinquantaine de
volontaires ont participé à cette
cinquième édition
ils ont été aidés par une association
d'attelage pour transporter les nombreux
déchets moi j'ai eu la chance de tomber
sur beaucoup de déchets surtout en
bordure de route
que ce soit des bouteilles de bière des
canettes etc et puis on est tombé sur
une carcasse de voiture une vieille ds
qu'on appuie désossée et démonter et
puis on a réussi à la ramener donc
autant en termes de quantité je pense qu
on avoisine peut-être les deux tonnes je
pense qu'il ya eu des abus peut-être
dans la chasse d'avant aujourd'hui c'est
plus comme ça il ya une nouvelle chasse
qui se met en place
on est à sa tête et voilà on veut faire
changer les choses que les gens nous
connaissent pourquoi on fait ça et je
pense qu'on a notre place aujourd'hui
dans l'environnement dans l'écologie
dans la nature après l'effort le
réconfort
un cocktail a terminé cette matinée tous
les abords des étangs de la minière sont
maintenant propre simplement à espérer
qu'il le reste
et c'est une nouveauté au château de
versailles il accueilli un nouveau
résident et il s'agit d'un grands noms
de la cuisine le 13 septembre dernier
alain ducasse à une oraison inauguré par
dont son restaurant aurait dans le
domaine du roi soleil il pourrait doper
la fréquentation et du château et à
donner
ciré de nouveaux visiteurs car comme
vous le savez les lieux touristiques ont
été impactés par les récents attentats
survenus en france petit tour de table
signés camille lambert un café
contemporain c'est en ces termes que se
présente le nouveau restaurant du
château de versailles aurait à sa tête
alain ducasse un rêve de longue date
pour ce chef étoilé passionné par le
domaine et son histoire
c'est juste l'histoire de france ce lieu
emblématique il est il est simplement
magnifique et je vais essayer d'y
recevoir les visiteurs de passage à
paris en particulier au château de
versailles pour qu'il garde un souvenir
indélébile du déjeuner ou du dîner
qu'ils auront fait ici dans un lieu
extraordinaire là je pense que c'est mon
rôle
inaugurée le 13 septembre
l'établissement a été installé au
pavillon dufour entièrement rénové il
propose une carte authentique en
d'accord avec le territoire local
ici on propose une cuisine axée sur le
produit très
alain ducasse voilà des condiments avec
des produits de saison restait respect
des cuissons respect des produits
nous sommes en train de
voir avec le potager du roi justement
pour éventuellement créer un partenariat
pour pouvoir
voilà acheter leurs produits
turbo à la vapeur suprême de pintade et
salade de homard compter entre 20 et 40
8 euros pour un plat au déjeuner le
château de versailles accueille plus de
7 millions de visiteurs par an sa
fréquentation avait baissé en 2015 après
les attentats l'ouverture de ce nouveau
restaurant pour elle a relancé et les
cyclisme sur piste à présent les
championnats du monde masters débutent
ce samedi à manchester une dizaine de
pistard de l'équipe de france se
déplaceront pour l'épreuve le dernier
rassemblement s'est tenu ce samedi au
vélodrome saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'entraînement des dix coureurs s'est
déroulée sous les yeux du parrain de la
section master quentin lafargue champion
de france de vitesse 2015 et double
médaillé de bronze aux championnats du
monde c'est impressionnant je vous
propose de l'écouter tout de suite il
était au micro de nicolas kirillovitch
les cdc leur faire profiter de mon
expérience du
mutuelle pour pouvoir alors permettre de
les aider à avancer après on a chacun
nos calendriers et je suis pas ultra
présent il frapperait d'emplois mais
mais
je trouve que voit il son règne il
s'organise pas mal et puis cette cime
cet hymne à la gueule quand même et aux
derniers championnats du monde la france
avait décroché trois médailles dont une
en titre individuel latine master espère
améliorer cette performance cette année
en terre britannique
pour finir je vous propose un mot de
football matchs est difficile pour
l'équipe de football de trappes qui
rentre et qui rencontraient pour le 4e
tour de la coupe de france à paris c'est
à qui évolue deux divisions au dessus de
l'étoile sportive les trappistes ont
souffert mais ont su s'imposer lors de
la séance de tirs au but de dire au vu
de pardon résumé du match par haussmann
vendeurs des c'est dans la douleur que
l'équipe de trappes s'est imposé hier
face au paris ca
et pourtant le match avait mal débuté
mené tout au long de la rencontre par
l'équipe adverse les trappistes ont tenu
bon
on a de la fierté c'est une belle
victoire
on revient deux fois au score on ça
prouve qu'on a un mental on a des choses
à corriger mais c'est encourageant pour
la suite
ça prouve qu'on s'est pas affolé sait on
revient deux fois au score rapidement on
se fait mener on a une belle équipe un
bon mental et ça va nous servir pour une
relation et c'est grâce à cette force et
cette cohésion d'équipé que le strap a
pu revenir au score à la dernière minute
du temps réglementaire et ensuite
maîtrisé cette séance de tirs au but
enfin l'équipe de la chaire k car façon
jeu on a été patient et arraché deux
donations faites en bout de course c'est
qu'on n'a pas lâché que c'est vraiment
l'esprit qu'il y en a encore ils
connaîtront leurs futurs adversaires
pour le prochain tour de la coupe de
france ce mardi 27 septembre à 18 heures
en attendant le strap se focalise sur le
championnat de ph
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous donne rendez vous mercredi pour un
nouveau agité devant ce sera à wilfrid
enrichi qui vous présentera le 7 8
l'aktu joue pas je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur tf1 il a 78